une fois de plus andré boisclair reste
muet devant les caméras en arrivant au
palais de justice de montréal l'ex chef
du parti québécois ancien ministre
rasent les murs il s'engouffre dans la
salle d'audience sachant qu'il y perd sa
liberté
andré boisclair purgera deux ans moins
un jour de prison pour avoir agressé
sexuellement une personne avec l'aide
d'un tiers et pour une agression
sexuelle sur une autre victime il aura à
sa sortie deux ans de probation où il
devra éviter de s'approcher des victimes
et n'aura le droit de consommer aucune
autre drogue que celle sous ordonnance
qu'à mon avis une peine de deux ans
moins un jour reste quand même une panne
importante donc ça envoie le message que
ce sont des gestes graves et qui sont
punis à la hauteur de leur gravité le
juge a souligné le courage des deux
victimes qui ont porté plainte contre le
politicien connu des clients sont venus
témoigner sur la peine ils ont livré un
vibrant témoignage des conséquences que
les gestes ont encore dans leur vie
aujourd'hui donc
on remercie tribunal d'avoir porté
attention à cet aspect là le juge a
justifié la peine par le début de prise
de conscience du délinquant en a tenu
compte des facteurs favorables à
l'accusé à savoir qu'il a entrepris une
thérapie par lui-même avant d'avoir à ce
qu'on lui impose il ya eu 10 suivie pour
voir si la le résultat cette thérapie sa
sobriété était respecté il en a fait la
démonstration par des tests sporadiques
qui ont été
déposés en cour le juge croit qu andré
boisclair représentent un faible risque
de récidive pour la société en est à une
personnalité publique connue ah bah je
vous dirais qu'une grande partie de la
sentence
il vole à purger mais pendant très
longtemps parce que sa carrière
personnelle professionnelle
en a pris pour son rhume pour les
centres des deux victimes d'actes
criminels l'apn et raisonnable c'est
quand même une sentence significative on
espère que ça va à la confiance des
personnes victimes envers le processus
judiciaire en plaidant coupable andré
boisclair a ainsi évité deux procès au
système de justice mais il a surtout
évité deux procès aux vies tim par
l'entremise du procureur elle se dit
soulagée et elle espère que
l'emprisonnement de leur agresseur
accélérer leur processus de guérison ici
marie josée paquet comme radio canada
montréal